se vi chiedessi quale di questi due
ritratti opera di un pittore quale
invece di un intelligenza artificiale
scommetto che non avreste alcun dubbio
quello di sinistra ovviamente è stato
prodotto da un algoritmo e più
precisamente da un sistema chiamato gun
che sta per generati avversari al
network è un sistema composto da due
algoritmi un algoritmo generativo che
genera le immagini è un discriminatore
ossia l'algoritmo che tenta di
selezionare quali immagini assomigliano
a un opera umana da quelle che invece
ritiene false
nel caso di questo pseudo ritratto a
sinistra il generatore tra l'altro
volevo dire questo ritratto è stato
venduto all'asta da christie's per 430
2.500 dollari
il generatore è stato nutrito da una
banca dati di circa 15.000 ritratti
dipinti tra il xiv e il ventesimo secolo
e fra le varie immagini ha prodotto
quella di sinistra che ha ingannato la
rete discriminatrice producendo lui il
fantomatico personaggio edmond bellamy
adesso volevo fare un esperimento
contrario se vi facessi vedere questi
quattro collaso un po metà tra
espressionismo e dada mi sapreste dire
quale di questi è opera di una mente
umana
sono sicuro che in questo caso avreste
più difficoltà
questi quattro ritratti questa sequenza
è stata prodotta da un'applicazione che
mi sono inventato io che è
un'applicazione per insegnare la storia
dell'arte ai bambini in maniera
divertente in maniera creativa
vi faccio una premessa io nasco come
pittore
purtroppo diciamo e il termine che oggi
mi definisce di più il termine artista
visivo che mi irrita moltissimo ma che
non capisco non so ancora cosa
significhi però credo che un po implichi
l'utilizzo di varie tecniche di vari
media ed io in questo senso devo dire
che ho iniziato dipingendo
tradizionalmente olio su tela e poi dopo
tanti anni ho cominciato ad interessarmi
anche di tecniche digitali e nel tempo
questi due aspetti hanno convissuto
sempre di più nel mio lavoro l'aspetto
analogico e l'aspetto digitale mi sono
laureato in filosofia
nei primi anni del 2000 con una tesi
sull'intelligenza artificiale
era una tesi su un autore americano che
si chiama hubert gryphus che scrisse nel
1972 un libro molto discusso ancora oggi
che si chiama what computer skate 2 cosa
i computer non possono fare in cui
fondamentalmente cercava di confutare
l'idea per cui i computer potessero
essere dotati di un autentica coscienza
diciamo che da quando mi sono laureato
già intelligenza artificiale ha fatto
dei progressi incredibili
basti pensare non so che un computer
oggi cosa che prima sembrava incredibile
poi ripetutamente umiliare a scacchi
il campione del mondo umano oppure
ancora indicarci il percorso più breve
per arrivare a una destinazione oppure
individuare un tumore con molta più
sicurezza di un dottore umano o ancora
abbiamo visto ultimamente guidare
autonomamente un veicolo mentre noi
stiamo comodamente seduti nel sedile
posteriore a leggere un libro
nonostante tutta questa serie di
progressi incredibili e anche nonostante
una serie di previsioni è completamente
sbagliate di chi pensava che le macchine
essere ormai avere una coscienza devo
dire che ancora oggi sento idealmente di
appartenere a quella schiera di
pensatori diciamo cosiddetti anti
riduzionisti ossia che pensavano
fondamentalmente che la coscienza fosse
irriducibile alle maglie del sapere
scientifico
certo la macchina è perfetta ed esegue
dei singoli i calcoli con una capacità e
una perfezione terrificante università
di calcolo terrificante ma è proprio
questo il mio punto c'è la macchina è
perfetta mentre noi umani siamo
meravigliosamente imperfetti un robot a
suo modo intelligentissimo è perfetto
sarebbe incapace di capire la bellezza
di un quadro di compiere quel salto
quasi metafisico che facciamo noi quando
abbiamo un intuizione un'idea quando
passiamo da dall entropia dal disordine
all'ordine da nulla a tutto dal normale
al sublime e il salto che facciamo noi
umani in maniera appunto quasi
metafisica quando bypassando la nostra
razionalità muoviamo la nostra mano
mossi dall inconscio mossi dall intuito
e la nostra mano il nostro pennello si
muove sulla tela e se va bene produce
misteriosamente bellezza è curioso
constatare come tre elementi come
l'imperfezione il caso è l'errore che
sono anche tre elementi fondamentali per
la nostra stessa evoluzione ed elementi
che ci rendono così straordinariamente
unici e complessi siano anche degli
elementi che io ritengo fondamentali
nella creatività e nel processo
artistico del mio non ne parliamo
volevo far vedere un piccolo estratto di
quella che io chiamo metamorfosi
pittoriche sono delle performance questa
è stata realizzata durante la l'ultimo
lockdown in cui dipingo liberamente non
so dove vado a finire improvviso e le
forme cambiano continuamente da una cosa
all'altra e questa tecnica la uso perché
mi aiuta a raggiungere dei risultati che
sorprendono me stesso
non so che cosa verrà fuori
e alla fine però avviene qualcosa di più
forte di più puro di più necessario
rispetto al tradizionale percorso
illustrativo
eccolo qua
[Musica]
ho aperto questa lunga parentesi perché
ho spesso pensato anche proprio a come
questa tesi che ho fatto
sull'intelligenza artificiale tanti anni
fa avesse un senso ulteriore anche
rispetto a questa mia piccola
preziosissima per me invenzione dell'app
in cui in qualche modo confluiscono la
mia filosofia creativa l'utilizzo di
nuove tecnologie anche questa mia vera e
propria ossessione per il caso come
metodologia creativa anche il percorso
che mi ha portato alla realizzazione
della peralta del tutto casuale mi
ricordo che la prima versione che veniva
utilizzata tra l'altro è forse ancora
viene utilizzata nella sala d'aspetto
dell'ospedale meyer dell'ospedale
pediatrico meyer qui a firenze era una
lavagna magnetica su cui i bambini
potevano manipolare e combinare dei
pezzi dei pezzi che erano estratti dai
loro disegni
oppure da oggetti di uso comune o da
forme che gli avevo disegnato e fornito
io mi ricordo ancora la prima volta che
li vidi creare dei piccoli capolavori
senza nessun bisogno di spiegazioni
tecnica assemblando veramente dei
collages delle opere incredibile
guardate meno portate 3 ma ce ne sarebbe
un infinità cose che farebbero bene in
un museo secondo me è ciò che volevo
realizzare in seguito però era un app
che aiutasse i bambini non solo a creare
ma anche ad imparare la storia dell'arte
in maniera divertente proprio perché
forse troppe volte io stesso mi ero
annoiato anche durante il liceo durante
queste lezioni di storia dell'arte pur
amando moltissimo
l'arte per cui partivo dall idea
semplice ma molto potente di manipolare
un campionario di pezzi estratti dai
grandi capolavori dell'arte e il fatto
che questi si fossero elementi discreti
per utilizzare un termine rubato dalla
fisica ossia elementi singoli elementi
separati l'uno dall'altro elementi
atomici si è rivelato un aspetto molto
molto importante
se ad esempio pensiamo di invece di
assemblare questi pezzi di assemblare le
parole anche se scegliessimo parole di
per sé meravigliose alla fine non
verrebbe più che un diverse un
divertente nonsense
ma mi resi conto che invece con i pezzi
la storia era diversa
la possibilità di realizzare questa mela
permetteva anche la nascita di questa
nuova tecnologia che era la tecnologia
touch
dopo che cominciai a selezionare questi
pezzi questi erano circa duecento pezzi
cosa che mi fa anche impressione perché
se ripensiamo ai 15.000 pezzi con cui è
stato nutrito l'algoritmo di prima
devo dire che non vorrei mettermi in
competizione ma ne esco abbastanza
vincitore questi 200 pezzi estrapolati
da grandi capolavori e dal duecento al
novecento tutti di pubblico dominio
messi insieme creano dei veri e propri
piccoli capolavori a mi ricordo mentre
lavoravo alla messa a punto di questa
app mio figlio leo che all'epoca aveva
poco più di tre anni è stato una specie
di piccolo direttore artistico
importantissimo per me perché vedevo
veramente la potenzialità di questa cosa
nelle mani di un bambino e vi ho portato
quattro collage realizzati da leo
a poco più di tre anni però mancava
ancora qualcosa
vi ricordate prima quando vi parlavo di
cosa si distingue dalle macchine tra le
altre cose
l'imperfezione e il caso dunque ebbe
l'idea di introdurre il caso nella mia
up sotto forma di un algoritmo un
algoritmo che chiama è appunto un
algoritmo e random che semplicemente
consisteva era allegato un gesto fisico
che era quello dello scuotimento del
device per cui uno componeva il proprio
quadro è il proprio collasso e poi
quando scuoteva il tablet
l'algoritmo cambiava liberamente i pezzi
con altri pezzi continuamente ogni volta
che si scuoteva l'ipad e questa cosa
ovviamente portava alla nascita di pezzi
completamente inaspettati
vi faccio vedere la cosa importante però
lo schema iniziale dell'opera che si era
creata veniva rispettato vi faccio
vedere una piccola sequenza di
scuotimento della mia up
queste sono tutte cose in mezzo alla
sequenza dello scuotimento quindi
nemmeno create da me mi potete
immaginare che praticamente ho passato
mesi a scuotere il device sotto gli
occhi atterriti della mia famiglia
ecco guardate che robe venivano fuori
insomma avete capito che per me il caso
è sicuramente una cosa
l'imperfezione l'errore è una cosa alla
base diciamo della creatività è vero poi
ogni tanto la nostra vita sembra essere
in balia del caos del caso pensiamo
anche alla pandemia che stiamo
attraversando
ed è per questo che proviamo anche
ad applicare alla realtà dei modelli di
perfezione che appunto per rimanere nel
tema di oggi ci rassicurano pensiamo ai
modelli di bellezza nei modelli di
successo ai modelli di perfezione
imposti dalla nostra società
però se ci pensate bene questa idea di
perfezione un'idea statica e un'idea
vuota è un'idea fredda la perfezione per
sua definizione non ha bisogno di
cambiamento l'imperfezione il caso sono
alla base della nostra stessa evoluzione
se fossimo stati perfetti non avremmo
nemmeno avuto bisogno di evolversi no e
quando da piccolo mi trovai provocato da
mio padre a pensare a questa idea di un
dio magico è perfetto disse questa frase
che oggi mi sembra emblematico
gli dissi papa se io fossi dio non
vorrei essere magico vorrei essere
normale cioè avevano già capito in
qualche modo che questa cosa della
perfezione non mi tornava era qualcosa
di noioso che non portava a niente di
buono
insomma l'imperfezione secondo me è ciò
che ci salva dall'omologazione ciò che
ci rende straordinariamente unici e
complessi è vero anche che il caso il
disordine da soli senza controllo non
sarebbero altro che entropia e arbitrio
ma proprio qui che noi umani ci possiamo
distinguere dalle macchine perché quando
si va bene possiamo prendere questo
disordine e dargli una forma e quando si
va bene gli possiamo dare una giusta
forma una bella forma e allora li
scopriamo che succedono cose
meravigliose per sorprendenti il caso è
una vera e propria forza vitale è una
vera e propria straordinaria forza
creativa
quando si avvicinava questo talk mi sono
trovato a fantasticare sul fatto che
forse i miei nipoti o i figli dei miei
nipoti un giorno potranno sentire questo
mio talk alt ed ex e magari saranno
circondati da automi intelligentissimi e
raffinatissimi con i quali magari si
prenderanno gioco del vecchio nonno che
invece pensava non credeva nell'ipotesi
dell'intelligenza artificiale forte ma
io sono profondamente convinto che c'è
una cosa che le macchine non possono
ancora autenticamente possedere ma solo
simulare ed è proprio questo il nostro
essere meravigliosamente imperfetti
grazie
[Applauso]